>>> WE DO HAVE BREAKING NEWS,
LOS ANGELES COULD BECOME THE
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
NATION TO REQUIRE VACCINATIONS
FOR STUDENTS 12 AND OLDER.
A VOTE IS PLANNED FOR TODAY.
IN THE MEANTIME, PRESIDENT BIDEN
WILL LAY OUT HIS
ADMINISTRATION'S REVAMPED
APPROACH TO ENDING THE PANDEMIC.
JOINING US NOW IS WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY GENJEN PSAKI, G
MORNING, THANKS FOR BEING WITH
US.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> THE NEWS OUT OF LOS ANGELES
DIRECTLY IMPACTS THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN SOON AND COULD
INFLUENCE THE COURSE FOR
MILLIONS OF OTHERS.
WHAT IS THE WHITE HOUSE VIEW.
>> GOOD FOR THEM.
>> GOOD FOR THEM?
>> ABSOLUTELY, JOHN.
WE KNOW IT WORKS IN SCHOOLS.
WE KNOW THAT GETTING YOUR KIDS
VACCINATED IF THEY'RE 12 AND
OLDER WORKS, PEOPLE WHO ARE
WORKING IN SCHOOLS WORKS, AND
FOR KIDS WHO ARE UNDER 12, THE
BEST THING WE CAN DO IS ENSURE
THAT EVERY ADULT AROUND THEM IS
VACCINATED, AND THIS TYPE OF
STEP IS A STEP TOWARDS THAT.
DEFINITELY A POSITIVE SIGN.
>> DOES THE WHITE HOUSE
ENCOURAGE SCHOOL DISTRICTS OR
STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY TO PUT
IN VACCINE MANDATES FOR
12-YEAR-OLDS AND OLDER.
>> WELL, LOOK, EVERY SCHOOL IS
GOING TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISION, BUT CERTAINLY PUTTING
IN PLACE REQUIREMENTS THAT WOULD
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE VACCINATED, DECREASE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNVACCINATED AROUND KIDS IS A
STEP FORWARD, AND SOMETHING,
YES, WE HAVE BEEN ENCOURAGING.
>> WILL THE WHITE HOUSE TAKE
FEDERAL ACTION IN ORDER TO GET
MORE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO DO
THIS?
>> WELL, IT'S ALWAYS UP TO LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO PUT IN PLACE
REQUIREMENTS, WHATEVER THEY ARE.
THERE'S A ROLE THAT LEADERS IN
STATES CAN PLAY.
THERE'S A ROLE THAT CIVIC
LEADERS CAN PLAY, AND SURE,
THERE'S A ROLE THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
CAN PLAY AS WELL.
HE'S GOING TO SPEAK LATER TODAY
ON THIS.
BUT PUTTING IN PLACE ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE MORE
PEOPLE ARE VACCINATED, KIDS ARE
PROTECTED, PARENTS CAN FEEL
CALMER ABOUT SENDING THEIR KIDS
TO SCHOOL, SOMETHING THAT'S KEY
FOR MENTAL HEALTH, EMOTIONAL
HEALTH, THAT CERTAINLY IS A PART
OF HIS SPEECH LATER THIS
AFTERNOON.
>> SO THE SPEECH TODAY, CAN I
ASK, IT'S A SIX-POINT PLAN,
WHAT'S THE OVERALL GOAL HERE.
>> THE OVERALL GOAL IS TO SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ABOUT WHAT'S NEXT ON COVID.
AND WE KNOW THAT WHILE THERE'S
BEEN A RANGE OF ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE ALL BEEN DISCUSSING, THAT'S
VITALLY IMPORTANT, AFGHANISTAN
OR THE BUILD BACK BETTER AGENDA,
MOST PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY,
COVID AND ADDRESSING COVID,
RETURNING TO SOME VERSION OF
NORMALCY IS THE NUMBER ONE, TWO,
AND THREE ISSUE.
WE'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE, AND
ALSO TALK ABOUT WHAT'S NEXT,
THAT INCLUDES GETTING MORE
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNVACCINATED,
VACCINATED.
THAT MEANS REDUCING
HOSPITALIZATIONS, PUTTING IN
PLACE MORE TESTING REQUIREMENTS
AND PUTTING IN PLACE MORE
PROTECTIONS IN THE FORM OF
BOOSTERS, TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
HAVE AN EVEN GREATER LEVEL OF
PROTECTION.
THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT WILL
TALK ABOUT.
HE'LL ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT
175 MILLION PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED OUT THERE, MANY OF
THEM ARE FRUSTRATED, THEY WANT
TO GO BACK TO NORMAL.
OF COURSE THEY DO, AND THAT IS
GOING TO REQUIRE MOVING MORE
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE TO A
VACCINATED STATUS, SO THAT'S
WHAT HE'LL TALK ABOUT.
>> WE HEARD HOWARD STERN,
MICHAEL SMERCONISH, JIM JUSTICE
IN WEST VIRGINIA, REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR, AND THEY'RE SICK OF
SORT OF I'M PARAPHRASING HERE,
CODDLING THE UNVACCINATED.
WHERE IS THE WHITE HOUSE ON
THIS?
>> THEY'RE NOT ALONE.
AND I THINK THAT IS REFLECTIVE
OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
WE DON'T WANT THIS TO BE A
VACCINATED VERSUS UNVACCINATED
ISSUE.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE AIMING
TOWARD OR LOOKING TWO DO HERE.
WHAT WE ARE FOCUSED ON DOING IS
PROTECTING MORE PEOPLE, AND YOU
STARTED OUR INTERVIEW HERE
TALKING ABOUT KIDS WHO ARE UNDER
12.
WE KNOW WHAT WORKS.
WE KNOW IF THEY'RE SURROUNDED BY
ADULTS WHO ARE VACCINATED, THEY
ARE GOING TO BE BETTER
PROTECTED.
WE KNOW HOW TO PROTECT PEOPLE
WHO ARE IMMUNOCOMPROMISED.
WE KNOW HOW WE CAN SAFELY GO
BACK TO SPORTING EVENTS, TO
CONCERTS, AND PEOPLE ARE SICK
AND TIRED OF WAITING.
WE KNOW REQUIREMENTS WORK.
WE HAVE PUT IN PLACE THE
MANDATES OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS FOR COMPONENTS OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
MANY BIG COMPANIES HAVE PUT IN
PLACE REQUIREMENTS.
WE HAVE SEEN THEM WORK.
THEY HAVE ALSO BECOME MORE
POPULAR, IN PART BECAUSE
VACCINATED PEOPLE WANT TO RETURN
TO SOME VERSION OF NORMAL.
>> I WANT TO RUN THROUGH MAJOR
OVERNIGHT DEVELOPMENTS ON
DIFFERENT FRONTS THAT I WANT TO
GET THE WHITE HOUSE POSITION ON.
WE LEARNED THAT THERE IS A PLANE
IN KABUL THAT WILL BE LEAVING AT
SOME POINT CARRYING AS MANY AS
200 PEOPLE, INCLUDING SOME
AMERICANS LEAVING FOR DOHA, WHAT
CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THIS?
>> I CAN'T GET INTO ANY SPECIFIC
DETAILS FOR SECURITY REASONS,
JOHN, BUT WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS
THAT ONE OF OUR FOCUSES, THE
FOCUS OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE
WHO HAS BEEN ON THE GROUND THE
LAST COUPLE OF DAYS, AND
DIPLOMATS IN THE REGION WORKING
O
OVERTIME IS TO GET THE AIRPORT
OPERATIONAL.
THE QATAR AIRLINE, THEY HAVE
BEEN A KEY PARTNER.
WE'RE WORKING TO GET FLIGHTS IN
AND OUT OF THE AIRPORT TO HELP
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO DEPART
DEPART.
AMERICAN CITIZENS, LEGAL
RESIDENTS, PEOPLE ELIGIBLE FOR
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS FROM THE
UNITED STATES, SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
VISA PROGRAMS AND OTHERS SO THIS
IS WHAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
TOWARD EVERY MOMENT OF EVERY
DAY, AND IT'S SOMETHING WE HOPE
WILL BE INSTRUMENTAL MOVING
FORWARD.
>> THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORTS THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO SUE
TEXAS TO TRY TO STOP THEIR NEW
NEAR ABORTION BAN FROM
CONTINUING.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, THE PRESIDENT ON THE
DAY THIS ANNOUNCEMENT WAS MADE
IN TEXAS, THE PRESIDENT MADE
PRETTY CLEAR TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES THAT
THEY WERE TO DO EVERYTHING THEY
COULD TO PROTECT A WOMAN'S RIGHT
TO HEALTH CARE, A WOMAN'S RIGHT
TO CHOOSE.
THERE WERE STEPS THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ANNOUNCED, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ANNOUNCED
ADDITIONAL STEPS THEY WERE
CONSIDERING.
WE'LL LET THEM ANNOUNCE LEGAL
ACTIONS FROM THEIR END, HOPE TO
HEAR MORE SOON.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S CALL FOR URGENCY AND
ACTION TO PROTECT WOMEN'S HEALTH
CARE IN TEXAS.
>> LAWSUIT ANNOUNCED TODAY?
>> WE'LL SEE.
WE'LL LEAVE IT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO ANNOUNCE ANY
SPECIFIC DETAILS OR PLANS.
>> SO THE WHITE HOUSE ASKED FOR
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THESE
MILITARY ACADEMY ADVISORY BOARDS
TO RESIGN OR THEY WOULD BE
REMOVED, MANY HAVE REFUSED TO
RESIGN, SO WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM
NOW?
>> WELL, WE'RE CONFIDENT IN OUR
LEGAL ABILITIES HERE, BUT I WILL
TELL YOU, JOHN, NO ONE IS
LOOKING TO HAVE A BATTLE HERE.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES JUST AS EVERY PRESIDENT
AND EVERY ADMINISTRATION AND
CABINET MEMBERS HAVE THE RIGHT
TO APPOINT PEOPLE THEY DEEM AS
QUALIFIED, AS ALIGNED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S, YOU KNOW,
PRIORITIES, TO THESE BOARDS AND
TO ANY POSITION IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT HERE.
WE'RE CONFIDENT IN OUR RIGHT TO
MAKE NEW DECISIONS ABOUT WHO
SERVES ON THESE BOARDS.
>> TRADITIONALLY, THESE
APPOINTEES DO SERVE OUT THEIR
FULL THREE-YEAR TERM, THOUGH,
WHY IS THERE NO DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THE LIKES OF KELLYANNE
CONWAY, AND MEAGHAN MOBS OR EVEN
GENERAL McMASTER RECEIVING AN
AWARD FROM WEST POINT LATER THIS
WEEK.
WHY NO DISTINCTION?
>> LOOK, AGAIN, THIS REALLY GOES
BACK TO WHAT EVERY PRESIDENT'S
RIGHT IS, WHICH IS TO APPOINT
INDIVIDUALS THEY CHOOSE BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALIGNED WITH THEIR
VALUES, ALIGNED WITH THE
QUALIFICATIONS THEY DEEM FOR ANY
OF THESE POSITIONS ON ANY OF
THESE BOARDS, AND THAT'S WHAT IS
TAKING PLACE HERE.
IT'S NOT PERSONAL.
I WILL SAY THAT THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE OF COURSE ON THESE BOARDS
WHO HAVE SUPPORTED OR STOOD BY
SILENTLY WHILE THEIR FORMER BOSS
SUPPORTED AN INSURRECTION,
THAT'S NOT REALLY OKAY WITH US
EITHER.
YOU'RE RIGHT, THERE'S A SPAN OF
INDIVIDUALS ON THESE BOARDS.
IT'S REALLY NOT MORE COMPLICATED
THAN THE PRESIDENT, HIS CABINET
AND TEAM WANTING TO BE ABLE TO
APPOINT A FRESH LAYER OF PEOPLE.
>> AS FAR AS YOU'RE CONCERNED,
ARE THEY EFFECTIVELY OFF THE
BOARDS NOW, HAVE THEY BEEN FIRED
FROM THESE BOARDS AS OF THIS
MORNING?
>> IT'S BEEN CONVEYED TO THEM AS
YOU KNOW YESTERDAY THAT THEY
WERE ASKED TO RESIGN IN TERMS OF
THEIR EXACT STATUS THIS MORNING,
I DON'T HAVE AN UPDATE.